musique avec le succès de ce groupe venu
d'irlande les cranberries qui est
actuellement en tournée mondiale avant
de se produire la semaine prochaine à
bercy olivier nuc zaré manche à plat
[Musique]
dolores o'riordan l'héroïne d'un vrai
conte de paix version rock'n'roll
dolores la petite dernière d'une famille
de sept enfants
élevé à la dure et puis un jour coup de
baguette magique en 1990 à l'âge de 19
ans arrive trois jeunes musiciens
les cranberries sonné
six ans plus tard le groupe a vendu 28
millions d'albums dans le monde
mais voilà bien évidemment le carrosse
est redevenu citrouille
[Musique]
vous savez c'est toujours la même chose
avec le succès les gens se servent de
vous il ya trop de pression et personne
ne vous alors on a tout arrêté on a dit
on fait une pause et pendant cette
période
petit à petit notre enthousiasme pour la
musique est revenu et nous avons
recommencé à écrire des chansons
ensemble
[Musique]
oubliée la dépression comme l'indiquent
leur dernier disque blu ray de hatchet
des cranberries enterrent la hache de
guerre et des terres après deux ans de
silence leurs instruments
[Musique]
m
qui
c'est très difficile de définir la voix
de dolores peut-être si différentes
montées très haut soprano ou alors allez
tout en bas c'est une voix très
particulière qui n'appartient qu'à elle
les cranberries refuse l'étiquette de
brit pop la pop venue d'angleterre
[Musique]
dolores et les siens ne revendique
qu'une seule influence leur pays
l'irlande
[Musique]